Here's an example from Sivic and
Zisserman in ICCV.
And the idea is that here we've carved
up feature space, sift or otherwise,
and the idea is that I've got in
this particular case three different
code words.
Here's a particular example.
So they are brought in from real images.
So you see one of the code words that
was found, I'm going to draw an example,
is basically a dark patch with a light
thing sticking out of the corner.
And these are taken from
lots of different images.
So that's like the eyeballs
that we saw before.
And the idea is that all of the points
here are an example of that.
So you could just say,
how many of these code words
show up in a particular picture?